[Musique]
merci xavieracovelli nous accompagne
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu des hautes membres du groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes indépendants groupe des
sénateurs de la majorité présidentielle
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales on va commencer
évidemment en parlant de ces marches
contre l'antisémitisme qui ont eu lieu
hier dans tout le pays 182000 personnes
est-ce que ce chiffre vous rassure
est-ce que le sursaut des Français là
oui écoutez un jour de pluie
avec la situation qui est celle de
d'aujourd'hui je pense queeffectivement
c'est un succès c'est un succès et c'est
plutôt rassurant effectivement que les
Français de toute confession de toute
sensibilité politique même si on pourra
reparler de certaines puissent se
mobiliser pour dire oui à la République
et non à l'antisémitisme et au racisme
en général donc oui je pense que c'est
un succès et je pense que c'était
nécessaire de faire cette marche on va
reparler des absents des présents le le
premier absent c'était Emmanuel Macron
le chef de l'État est-ce qu'il a commis
une faute comme l'a dit Eric chotti non
je pense pas qu' qu'il ait de faute du
président de la République il a mobilisé
son gouvernement et la première d'entre
elles la première ministre il a écrit au
français la veille justement pour à la
fois pour donner son point de vue pour
appeler les Français à se lever contre
l'antisémitisme et le racisme il a été
sans ambiguïé depuis les attaques du 7
octobre les attaques du du ramas contre
contre Israël je pense que la place du
président de la République n'est pas
forcément dans un dans un défilé mais
pourquoi puisqu'il se dit garant de
l'unité nationale est-ce que sa place
n'était pas il est garant de l'unité
nationale il a fait en sorte il s'est
exprimé auprès auprès des Français la
place du président de la République
n'est pas dans une manifestation il est
là surtout pour être le garant des
institutionsé François Hollande a défilé
en jean oui mais sauf que il faut se
rappeler aussi ce ce que ce quiétait la
manifestation du 2015 2015 nous étions
attaqués directement sur notre sol je
dis pas qu'on l'est pas avec ces actes
antisémites mais il y a eu des morts il
y a eu la Nation toute entière était
choquée par par ces attaques et par ces
actes terroristes on avait besoin
effectivement d'unité et nous
accueillons des des des chefs d'État
étrangers qui étaient qui avit fait le
déplacement pour soutenir la France dans
cette démarche là c'est différent c'est
une question française où effectivement
c'est la première le premier pays qui
fait une marche aussi importante contre
l'antisémitisme il était important que
les membres du gouvernement que la
majorité présidentiel soit présent et il
y avait les trois/arts du gouvernement
autour de la première ministre et et des
présidents des chambres je pense que il
y a il y a pas besoin de polémiquer sur
l'absence du du président de la
République qui s'en est expliqué bien un
amant et qui a écrit au français la
veille autre absent Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui dans un tweet hier soir a qualifié
cette marche d'échec on va le lire son
tweet toute la droite et l'extrême
droite pourtant unie ont échoué à
reproduire les mobilisations générales
du passé le rejet de l'antisémitisme est
plus large en France ils l'ont rabouriis
et rendu IG qu'est-ce que vous dites de
ce tweet honnêtement au-delà de
l'absence de Jean-Luc Mélenchon je je et
en plus des des polémique qui n'a aucun
sens il parle de la droite et de
l'extrême droite je rappelle que il y
avait le Parti socialiste qui avait
Europe Écologie Les Verts il y avait le
Parti communiste donc ces partenaires de
laanupes étaient représentés seul fi
n'était pas représenté et c'est ça
aujourd'hui le problème moi je pense que
nous avions besoin hier d'unité quelle
que soit notre sensibilité politique et
je combats un certain nombre de partis
politiques de de l'extrême droite
notamment mais aussi un certain nombre
de de de gauche et pourtant je pense que
tout le monde avait sa place hier dans
ce
rassemblement pour la République et
contre l'antisémitisme je pense que
c'est une erreur de la part de de de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de ne pas de ne pas
être présent ou en tout cas de ne pas
avoir fait représenter LFI dans dans
cette marche alors après effectivement
je peux comprendre qu'il ne souhaite pas
venir puisque les propos sont déjà
ambigus sur la question de
l'antisémitisme et donc euh je je peux
comprendre qu'il soit mal à l'aise à
défendre à défendre la
République VI pas quef vient pas en
raison de la présence du du
rassemblement national c'était un
prétexte mais c'est un prétexte je si le
rassemblement national n'était pas venu
il ne serait quand même pas pas présent
donc aujourd'hui le rassemblement
national et et et reconquête Zemour
était en fin de cortège il n'était pas
associé à la représentation nationale
aux institutions qui étaient en tête de
cortège les partis de gauche avaient
décidé de faire effectivement euh on va
dire banderôle commune au milieu du
cortège soit ils auraient très bien pu
elle et fille auraient très bien pu
s'associer avec leurs partenaires de
gauche ou faire une une une
manifestation à côté en parallèle de de
de ce rassemblement ils ont fait un
choix différent et je pense en fait que
c'est à l'image de de ce parti c'est
quoi c'est quoi l'image aujourd'hui bah
c'est un c'est une image qui qui
aujourd'hui est un parti révolutionnaire
qui se dit révolutionnaire qui est très
ambigu effectivement sur la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme un parti wiste et qui
aujourd'hui effectivement n'est plus en
n'est plus à l'intérieur du de l'arc
républicain c'est bien le problème vous
venez de la gauche vous est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
habîme la gauche ah mais je pense que il
y a une responsabilité à gauche
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'on est un le
premier parti de la gauche ce qui a été
le PS longtemps on a une responsabilité
qui est plus importante celle d'être le
leader de porter un certain nombre de
valeurs le Parti socialiste a longtemps
porté les valeurs effectivement de lutte
contre le racisme de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme les valeurs de la
République d'humanisme et aujourd'hui
cette responsabilité à l'incombe à Lafi
puisque c'est le premier parti de la
gauche et on voit bien que ce n'est plus
le cas et effectivement par cette
attitude elle entraîne la Lafi entraîne
l'ensemble de la gauche dans le mur mais
est-ce qu'il y a une responsabilité du
PS de rester avec LFI écoutez moi j'ai
entendu des propos de de Monsieur
rouscel hier qui alors il faut vérifier
les informations mais qui disait que le
Parti communiste devait sortir sortir de
l'ANU je pense qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui si la gauche veut se
reconstruire si la gauche veut assumer
les valeurs qui qui sont les siennes il
faut effectivement se détacher
définitivement de la LFI qui n'incarne
plus les valeurs de gauche en tout cas
celle qu'on nous nous connaissions et
celle qui moi m'a fait m'engager en
politique autre sujet de polémique c'est
la présence du rassemblement national
Gérard Larché elbrune Pivet à l'origine
de de cette marche ont déploré les
polémique né de né de la venue du du RN
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord vous savez
moi je me suis engagé en politique le 21
avril 2002 contre Jean-Marie Le Pen ça a
été mon premier engagement j'avais 21
ans donc moi je ne peux pas être taxé de
de de soutenir une nonce des des
propositions de l'extrême droite et
pourtant moi je pense que quand on a des
je suis d'accord avec édard Philippe sur
ce qu'il disait tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que lorsque nous avons des
la République qui est attaquée quand
nous avons nos valeurs qui sont
attaquées c'est l'unité nationale que
nous appelons et quelle que soit nos
sensibilités on combattra et on va
combattre et on compte continue à
combattre les idées du rassemblé
national au Parlement sur le terrain
dans dans toutes nos prises de parole
publi après quand il faut se rassembler
pour la République et contre
l'antisémitisme tout le monde a sa place
et d'ailleurs je pense que cé avant tout
un rassemblement citoyen il y avait pas
de rassemblement politique il n'y avait
pas d'étiquette politique personne
n'avait son drapeau de de parti dans
dans cette marche et je pense que
c'était important mais est-ce que les
polémiques elles ont pas été entretenues
aussi par Olivier Verron notamment qui a
déploré la présidence du la présence du
rassemblement national mercredi après le
conseil des ministres hier dans le
Parisien c'était opportun cette
déclaration écoutez moi je vous ai
donner mon opinion je ne juge pas
l'opinion des ministres les ministres
s'expriment soit à titre personnel soit
au nom d'un collectif aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il y a un certain nombre de
pris de parole de la majorité
présidentielle qui ont dit que la place
euh de des citoyens français c'était
dans cette marche cétait pour appeler un
sursaut citoyen je pense que le sursaut
a eu lieu euh et euh et que nous devons
mettre fin à toute polémique sur les
présents ou les absents Gérard Larché
qui a dit il faudra que cette marche
conduise à une démarche laquelle selon
vous écoutez euh on on verra euh ce que
ce queon pourra avoir en débat au sein
du Parlement est-ce que ça va est-ce
qu'on va légiférer euh euh plus sur
cette questionlà je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on ait besoin de plus de lois on a
déjà des lois qui sont très efficaces
après il faut effectivement les
appliquer la première ministre l'a
indiqué hier le ministre de l'Intérieur
également nous avons euh euh la police
la justice qui sont mobilisé aujourd'hui
pour répondre et ne rien lâcher sur les
actes ou les propos antisémites sur la N
les négationistes également sur
l'apologie du terrorisme moi je pense
notamment à la fois à l'influenceuse qui
avait remis en cause et et ironisé sur
ce bébé mis dans un dans un four dans un
kibuts en Israël je pense
qu'effectivement David guireot et ses
propos le député LFI du Nord les propos
quasi négationnistes sur sur ce sur ce
fameux bébé mort je pense effectivement
il y a eu un un certain nombre
d'articles 40 qui ont été déposés pour
porter plainte contre ce député et je
pense qu'il ne faut rien laisser passer
à la fois sur la question du racisme sur
la question de l'antisémitisme et sur
les attaque à notre République on va
parler de l'actualité du Sénat le Sénat
qui a terminé vendredi l'examen du
projet de loi immigration le texte sera
voté demain par les sénateurs il a été
considérablement modifié par la majorité
sénatoriale de la droite et du centre
alors que contient ce texte à sa sortie
du Sénat on voit ça avec Alex
[Musique]
Poussard bonjour Alex bonjour Rian
bonjour Xavier cowelli bonjour et Alex
quel projet de loi immigration va
ressortir de l'examen du Sénat et bien
la majorité de droite et du centre du
Sénat a effectivement voté plusieurs
durcissements de ce projet loi
immigration les sénateurs ont par
exemple permis au Parlement d'instaurer
chaque année des quotas d'immigration il
sera également plus difficile d'accéder
au regroupement familial et puis le
Sénat a restreint le panier de soins de
l'aide médicale d'État qui devient une
aide médicale d'urgence et après de
longues négociations les sénateurs les
républicains et les sénateurs centristes
se sont mis d'accord pour durcir les
conditions de régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension l'article 3 du projet
de loi prévoyait à la base une
régularisation de plein droit de ses
travailleurs il a été supprimé par les
sénateurs et remplacé par un article 4
bis qui prévoit des décisions des
préfets au cas par cas en tout cas tous
ces durcissements du projet de loi
immigration ils ont été vivement
critiqués dans l'hémicycle par la gauche
écoutez Yannick jade l'immigration
serait incontrôlable c'est faux aucune
statistique ne le valide ce débat est un
débat parallèle est un un monde
parallèle par rapport à la réalité et
Alex la majorité sénatoriale a également
facilité les expulsions de certains
étrangers et oui les sénateurs ont voté
des amendements qui qui permettent à
l'état d'expulser encore plus facilement
les étrangers délinquants et criminels
ou qui représenteraient une menace pour
l'ordre public ils ont aussi lever les
protections contre l'expulsion dont
peuvent bénéficier certains étrangers en
situation irrégulière écoutez Breno
rotao le président du groupe les
républicain au Sénat comment voulez-vous
que les Français
comprennent que ce sont des individus
étrangers très dangereux qui parfois ont
été condamnés très sévèrement y compris
par des crimes de sang pour des crimes
de sang comment voulez-vous que les
Français nos compatriotes comprennent
que on protège ces individus et qu'on
laisse exposer à leur menac à leur
violence à leur barbarie les Français
honnêtes paisiblebles et puis pour
rendre ces expulsions effective le Sénat
a permis au gouvernement à l'avenir de
conditionner l'aide publique au
développement versé à certains pays
pauvres au retour dans ces mêmes pays de
leur ressortissant expulsés par la
France Dav acovelli ce texte modifié par
le Sénat va maintenant aller à
l'Assemblée nationale l'examen ce sera
début décembre quelle mesure ajouté par
les sénateurs faut-il absolument retiré
quelles sont les lignes rouges selon
vous bah déjà moi je je je note que les
débats se sont correctement passés il
n'y a pas eu d'invective et c'était pas
gagné d'avance sur un texte aussi
clivant en tout cas avec notamment la
majorité éire c'était un texte qui est
un texte le plus dur sur l'immigration
depuis les 30 dernières années donc moi
je veux bien qu'on qu'on raconte la
petite histoire que ce sont les LR et la
majorité sénatorielle qui ontendci le
texte c'était déjà un texte qui était
très dur et qui était attendu par les
Français et proposé par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et toutes ces négociations
tout ces compromis qui ont été faits
effectivement avec la majorité
sénatoriale ont permis d'arriver sur un
texte qui sera normalement voté
majoritairement demain au Sénat donc il
y a un certain nombre de lignes rouges
un certain nombre de dispositions que
nous nous souhaitons revoir réintégrer
au sein euh de l'Assemblée nationale
avec nos collègues députés et notamment
la question de laame l' médical d'État
qui a été supprimé par la majorité
sénatoriale et remplacé par l'A médicale
d'urgence je rappelle que l'aide
médicale d'urgence c'est quoi c'est
passer directement sur des soins
d'urgence aux urgence c'est-à-dire à
l'hôpital faut savoir que une journée
d'hôpital un passage aux urgences ça
coûte 2000 € à l'assurance maladie nous
nous souhaitons en maintenant
l'assurance enfin le l'aide médicale
d'État nous souhaitons effectivement que
toute la médecine de ville comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui puisse êt mobilisé et
donc que ça coûte moins cher aussi c'est
une question économique pour nos nos
finances publiques on en parlera
certainement dans le projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale mais il y
a une volonté des LR de durcir c'est un
peu un maronnier à chaque projet de loi
de finance de la sécurité sociale la
majorité LR supprime les l'aide médicale
d'État je pense que c'est une des lignes
rouges sur lequel en tout cas nous on
s'est positionné clairement au sein du
groupe R naissance au Sénat et nous
aspirons à ce que nos collègues députés
puissent le réintégrer à l'Assemblée
nationale et puis après moi je regrette
juste effectivement qu'un certain nombre
de d'amendements quasi identiques a été
votés entre le rassemblement national et
leslr je pense notamment à l'allongement
sur la la durée pour le de résidence
pour avoir la naturalisation par exemple
Valérie Boyer et et le sénateur ravier
ont voté le même amendement ont présenté
le même amendement ce qui quand même
montre un peu une dérive d'un certain
nombre de LR vers l'extrême droite donc
ça je peux le regretter après sur la
question de l'article 3 est-ce qu'il
faut le rétablir avec cette
régularisation de de plein droit des
travurs on peut se dire que c'est la la
majorité LR qui a durci mais enfin
l'article 3 c'est quoi on a supprimé
l'article 3 pour à la fois permettre OLR
de ne pas perdre la face mais en fait on
l'a réécrit par amendement à l'article 4
et en fait qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
les les avec des contrôles plus stricts
des décisions au cas par cas des pré
d'accord alors dans le texte dans le
texte initial on disait quoi on disait
il faut que ça soit le Parlement qui
fixe les critèes et qui donne son sa
position sur le fait de
régulariser les travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension donc c'était bien
c'était le Parlement qui maîtrisait là
la majorité LR a dit quoi non on remet
ça dans la décision des préfets au cas
par cas très bien donc c'est le ministre
de l'Intérieur qui pourra par décision
auprès des préfets régulariser et donc
d'ailleurs le ministre de l'Intérieur
l'a dit Gérard lamanin l'a dit en séance
dit vous vous me faites un cadeau en
gros vous vous me permettez moi de
prendre la décision sans passer par le
Parlement donc moi je veux bien que
qu'on raconte une histoire pour que
personne perde la face la réalité c'est
que nous nous avons gagné ce que nous
voulions c'est-à-dire nous voulions
avoir une accroche législative sur cette
régularisation des métiers en tension
c'est un travail qui a été fait une
négociation qui a été fait de long long
terme avec Olivier du sopt géraldeanin
et la majorité sénatoriale l'article 3
est supprimé l'article 4 bis et enfin
après l'article 4 a été ajouté par
amendement et donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a un texte équilibré
sur cette question là en tout cas donc
il faut il faut vous pouvez garder la
version du Sénat sur cet article 3 vous
demandez à l'assemblée de garder la
version du sén pense je pense qu'en tout
cas si on veut trouver un compromis et
qu'on nous puissions avoir un accord
entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat sur cet
article 3 qui était un un des points
clivants il faut effectivement que nous
puissions avancer avec l'Assemblée
nationale et moi ça ne me dérange pas
alors après on peut avoir des
aménagements à la marge de de de cet
article 3 mais enfin de ce nouvel
article 3 donc après l'article 4 mais
globalement je trouve que on peut aller
vers un vote conforme sur ce sur ce
texte parce que Bruno reetillot enfin
sur cet article et pas sur la la pardon
C AR voilà parce que Bruno retaillot dit
en commission mixte paritaire donc quand
il faut trouver un accord entre députés
et sénateurs si les députés reviennent
sur l'article 3 si les députés
reviennent sur la me il y aura pas
d'accord pour vous pour nous c'est une
ligne rouge est-ce que pour vous un
compromis est possible du coup écoutez
moi je je je je souhaite un compromis je
note juste que Bruno rotillou avait dit
que si un article 3 MIM réécrit ça sera
une ligne rouge et on le votera pas bon
forcé de constater que le débat
parlementaire fait aussi que il y a des
majorité il y a des oppositions il y a
des compromis à trouver et pour Infiné
et moi je salue la décision du président
Larché qui voulait absolument qu'un
texte puisse sortir du Sénat pour aussi
l'image du du Sénat c'est la première
fois qu'on avait un texte régalien qui
passait en en première fois au au Sénat
donc on avait besoin d'un texte moi je
trouve que le bicamérisme c'est aussi
une négociation entre nos deux chambres
et donc il faudra qu'on trouve un accord
mais moi à titre personnel je souhaite
que l'ame soit réintégrée et qu'on
puisse maintenir l'article 4 après
l'article dle 3 estce que la majorité à
l'Assemblée l'ensemble de la majorité va
dans votre sens ou est-ce que cette
majorité sera fracturée lors de l'examen
non je pense pas que la majorité sera
fracturée il y aura des discussions il y
aura des débats on a une réunion
aujourd'hui enfin ce matin après le
plateau pour pour justement faire un peu
le bilan de de l'examen de de de ce
projet de loi au Sénat et donc on va
voir quels sont les amendements portés
par la majorité présidentielle à
l'Assemblée mais globalement je trouve
qu'on on a tout intérêt à trouver un
accord et faire en sorte que ce texte
soit équilibré et soit voté par la
majorité présidentielle à l'Assemblée
peut-être une question juste sur cette
majorité présidentielle il y a quand
même le président de la de la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée Sacha AER alors
qu'il fait partie de l'aile gauche de la
majorité présidentielle mais qui dit cet
article 3 modifié par les sénateurs
seignett on va rétablir la
régularisation de plein droit de ces
travailleurs sans papier donc ça montre
qu'il y a des divisions au sein de la
majorité qui qui est des débats il a pas
de division il y a des débats enfin on n
pas de mon impératif on il est très il
est très clair en on on a chacun des
position et moi je suis globalement sur
sa position je pense effectivement qu'il
faut attendez il accepte pas le
l'article de compromis naccepte pas on
peut être d'accord sur le fond
c'est-à-dire effectivement d'avoir une
régularisation de plein droit mais après
il y a une un principe de réalité c'estd
pour trouver une majorité et pour faire
en sorte que ce texte soit voté il faut
qu'on fasse des compromis et le
président de la commission des lois
Sacha alier devra faire des compromis
aussi pour pour faire en sorte que ce
texte soit voté donc c'est ce que je dis
je suis d'accord avec lui sur le fond
mais après il y a un principe de réalité
et pour que ce texte soit voté un mot
sur un aut texte c'est le budget de la
Sécurité sociale qui arrive cet
après-midi vous êtes le vice-président
de la commission des affaires sociales
ce budget il arrive au Sénat alors que
le gouvernement a déclenché le 493 à
l'Assemblée c'est-à-dire qu'il a
désormais la main sur le texte est-ce
que l'examen au Sénat va servir à
quelque chose oui parce que même si on a
un 493 à l'Assemblée nationale les
débats au Sénat apporte toujours des
avancé dans les textes budgétaires et je
pense que cette année ne ne fera pas
défaut on on a un certain nombre de
propositions nous le groupe RDPI on a un
certain nombre de de d'amendements aussi
que nous portons notamment sur la
question des pensions de reversion sur
les personnes handicapées les orphelins
handicapés on a voilà un certain nombre
de propositions qui qui nous permettront
aussi d'avancer moi je je souhaite qu'on
que le gouvernement puisse avancer dans
le cadre du PLFSS mais aussi par la
suite sur la question des droits euh
familiaux et les droits qui ont qui
doivent aussi évoluer par rapport aux
familles qui ont évolué et tout ça ce
sont des projets nouveaux euh avec euh
la question de l'autonomie aussi avec un
vrai budget quasiment 400 milliards de
de qui ont été euh consacrés à
l'autonomie dans ce projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale donc on
voit qu'il y a des avancées et donc il
faut à mon avis euh aller dans ce sens
et des points qui sont pas tranchés par
le gouvernement notamment la question de
l'augmentation des franchises c'est ce
qui reste à la charge des des patients
quand ils vont chez le médecin quand ils
achètent des médicament est-ce qu'il
faut les augmenter alors il faut être
aussi clair avec ceux qui nous écoutent
avec les Français qui nous écoutent la
question des franchises c'était avant
tout d'augmenter jusqu'à de 50 centimes
ou d'un € selon la consultation ou les
médicaments la franchise médicale mais
le ministre Aurélien Rousseau le
ministre de la Santé avait obtenu en
arbitrage ministériel que on maintienne
le plafond à 50 € maximum par par an
c'est-à-dire que toutes tous les
maladies toutes les maladies chroniques
ils sont déjà au plafond sans augmenter
les franchises ils utilisent déjà les 50
€ de de plafond à à l'année donc ça ne
touchera pas les maladies longue durée
ça ne touchera pas les femmes enceintes
puisqu'on maintient effectivement ce
cette franchise pour les femmes
enceintes ça ne touchera pas les mineurs
en fait ça touchera les citoyens qui
utilisent régulièrement et peut-être
parfois un peu trop un certain nombre de
médicaments ou des consultations chez
les généralistes qui peuvent qui peuvent
se multiplier donc c'est une économie
effectivement une recette supplémentaire
de 800 millions d'euros dans les caisses
de l'État qui vont nous permettre de
financer de nouveaux projets et de
nouveau de nouvelles protections pour
les Français donc ce n'est pas encore
arbitré mais je pense que c'est
intéressant aussi d'avoir les vrais
chiffres et de voir que nous continuons
à protéger les Français merci Alex on
continuera dans le club en tout cas à
parler de la loi immigration ce sera à
suivre on va voir l'actualité dans votre
région maintenant Xavier yacobelli on
trouve Jacques Paquier directeur de la
rédaction du journal du Grand Paris
Jacques bonjour vous vouliez revenir sur
un autre sujet avec Xavier yacovelli
c'est la crise du secteur immobilier son
impact sur les finances des
collectivités oui euh bonjour Orian on
va continuer en effet de parler de de
chiffres si vous voulez bien le je
voulais savoir Monsieur le Sénateur si
vous étiez inquiet à la veille du du
Congrès des Maires y compris pour les
collectivités des hautes scènes qu'on a
pas forcément l'habitude de plaindre
puisquelle elle bénéficie d'une relative
prospérité en l'occurrence quelques
chiffres le le nombre de transactions a
baissé de 22 % au premier sur l'ensemble
de la France he au premier trimestre
2023 par rapport à 2022 et c'est un
impact direct via les droits de mutation
à titre onéreux les fameux frais de
notaire puisque j'ai regardé il
représente jusqu'à 39 % des recettes du
département notamment est-ce que
Monsieur yakovelli il faut s'inquiéter
quand on sait que les collectivités se
sont pris déjà si j'ose dire la
l'inflation de l'énergie sont sont
victime entre guillemets de l'inflation
plus que la moyenne de l'inflation du du
panier du consommateur faut faut-il par
exemple comme le réclame l'Association
des maires de France indexer la la
dotation globale de fonctionnement c'est
un peu technique mais sur l'inflation
alors oui moi je je je suis
effectivement très inquiet de de cette
baisse des droits de mutation qui qui
finance nos nos départements en parti
nos
départements je ne suis pas forcément
favorable à l'indexation de la DGF sur
sur l'inflation et notamment parce que
moi je suis plutôt favorable à une
refonte globale de la question des
dotations de l'État aux collectivités
locales vous savez moi dans ma campagne
sénatoriale euh là jusqu'en jusqu'en
septembre avant la réélection c'était
une vraie crainte des des collectivités
locales et des et des maires qui
soulevaient la perte d'autonomie fiscale
pas d'autonomie financière l'autonomie
financière ils ont toujours les
collectivités locales ont toujours cette
autonomie financière de choix de
dépenses mais en terme de fiscalité
effectivement les communes perdent de
cette autonomie et donc je pense qu'il
faut aujourd'hui revoir globalement
cette question de de la fiscalité locale
comment est-ce qu'on recrée un lien
entre le citoyen et la collectivité
locale quand on n'est pas propriétaire
aujourd'hui on ne paye plus du tout on a
plus de lien fiscal avec la commune dans
laquelle nous vivons et donc c'est il y
a aussi toute cette question à revoir je
pense que c'est important de d'aller au
bout après c'est un gros chantier il
faut se le dire c'est un gros chantier
est-ce que un gouvernement quel que le
soit le gouvernement aura le courage de
de remettre ça sur la table moi en tout
cas c'est une un des engagements que
j'ai pris auprès des maires de mon
département de pouvoir retravailler sur
cette question de la fiscalité locale de
revoir les bases foncières aussi avec la
possibilité notamment de revoir les
droits de les les bases foncières au
moment des mutations on parlait
justement des mutations ce qui permet de
créer des ressources supplémentaires aux
communes au fur à mesure sans impacter
directement le contribuable qui est là
depuis longtemps et donc tout ça c'est
un débat qu'il faut avoir en fait sur
cette question de la fiscalité locale il
faut être en cononstruction avec les
maires et avec les collectivités locales
et c'est vraiment l'enjeu aujourd'hui
des prochaines des prochaines années
merci Xav Covelli merci Jacques paquet
on parlera de décentralisation très
rapidement avec vous Jacques on regarde
la Une du journal du Grand Paris le
Grand Paris se raconte à travers les
popées du métro c'est à la Une de votre
journal cette semaine merci Jacques
Paquier merci xavovelli d'avoir été avec
nous pendant cette première dem